Eine sehr wichtige Sache für uns
YouTube in Deutschland ist es, über die Missionsschulter zu sprechen.
Das ist der YouTube-
Star. Ja, es ist ein YouTube-Star in
Deutschland. Er hat vor einem Jahr seine erste eigene
Single veröffentlicht und jetzt ist er hier und
jetzt denken wir ein bisschen der wirkliche Erfolg
kann kommen ja glaubst du er hat eine
chance die stimme deutschlands zu gewinnen ja
ich habe offensichtlich ich bin voreingenommen weil er
in meinem team ist ja es ist witzig ich kam
gerade vor ein paar minuten vom coachen meines
cousins und hab ihm das gesag
Einer der Songs, die er singt, ist ein Song, den
ich nie wirklich gemocht habe, aber wenn er das singt
, liebe ich ihn wirklich
und ich kann nicht sagen, dass ich es bin, weil es ein Song ist
, den die Leute in der Show sehen werden.
Ja, ok, ok, ich muss ihn behalten  Geheimnis,
ja, aber das ist es, was ich so großartig
an Michael finde, denn er war eine erstaunliche
Stimme und er ist auch ein Künstler. Selbst
wenn er die Lieder anderer Leute singt,
macht er sie zu seinen eigenen, und ich denke,
das ist die Gabe eines Großen
Sänger, dass sie ihren identit setzen können
Bei Songs denke ich, dass es sich lohnt, sich daran zu erinnern,
dass Leute wie Frank Sinatra
nie einen Song geschrieben haben, er hat nie einen Song geschrieben, er hat
einfach die Songs anderer Leute gesungen, genauso wie
Elvis, viele der großartigen Stimmen, die
sie hatten, diese Gabe, Sie wissen, es gab
großartige Interpreten, die Michael hat  das, aber
ich denke auch, dass Michael auch ein großartiger
Songwriter sein könnte, ja, ja, auf
jeden Fall, und die Leute lieben ihn, du weißt, dass
die Öffentlichkeit ihn liebte, sie haben ihn
durch seine gewählt, woher es kommt, von
seiner Seele, von seinem Körper, wie er eine
fantastische Stimme hat  ein bisschen ein Geheimnis für
mich, weil er nicht so ein
kleiner Kerl ist, der groß ist, aber das ist er nicht. Er ist
kein großer Kerl
Es ist keine Schüchternheit, es ist
nur sehr, er ist ein wirklich interessanter
Typ, er ist sehr nett von Ihnen, wissen Sie, was ich
über Leute sage, die nicht immer
extravagant sind, aber eine echte Persönlichkeit haben,
gleichzeitig ist Michael so und ich
denke, das ist es, was m  Wenn er sinkt
, bewegen sie sich. Ich meine, er singt und es
bringt mich zum Weinen. Ja, aber das liegt daran, dass er
es ernst meint, weißt du, und er ist ein wirklich
ehrlicher Sänger, und er versucht nicht,
tausend Töne pro Minute zu machen, er
versucht nicht, wie Taio zu klingen
Cruz, du weißt, du weißt, dass er das nicht
tut, ich mag das manchmal,
aber ich habe es satt, diese Art
von Gesang zu hören, ja, er singt das, was
ich das Herz der Note nenne, also wenn er
denkt, dass es wirklich bewegend und lustig ist, ist es ein bisschen
voreingenommen  über uns gut Ich liebe unsere
Gruppe Ich liebe die vier Leute in unserer
Gruppe, dass es schwer war, wir
haben einige wundervolle Sänger verloren Ich war so traurig
, Charles Simmons gehen zu sehen, weil
Charles ein bemerkenswerter Sänger ist, aber ich
sehe mir die vier Leute an  In unserer Gruppe und
jeder persönlich Bernie Michael
Yasmine, sie alle haben Stärken und
individuelle Stärken, eine einzigartige Stärke,
also denke ich, dass es jetzt wirklich schwierig und
spannend wird